we cannot leave her alone in poland ina
baranov was desperate to get her mother
home having already endured the
terrifying early days of the russian
invasion alone in odessa she was
stranded in poland waiting for a
canadian visa no no i thought it's gonna
be fast because my mom
she is first 85 years old second she has
place to go she got depressed you know
because she said how long how long the
baranovs did not have an answer after
several weeks waiting with her mother
baranov's husband ran out of vacation
time so she had to fly to warsaw to take
his place
alexandra aslanova and her two young
daughters were facing a similar
frustration in germany her sister's home
in winnipeg had beds and toys to welcome
them but after submitting three visa
applications only one had come through
it's so cruel when when you give a visa
to one family member but not another the
worst thing is that there's nobody to
to talk to you have to deal with
some
website run by
a company which is not even the part of
the government what i saw there was
really
shocking and embarrassing and i felt
like somewhere between nausea and like i
wanted to cry alexander polowski found
this scene at canada's visa processing
office in berlin
after trying to help a ukrainian woman
navigate the system he was surprised to
find the place inaccessible to those who
had traveled there some of them had been
telling me that they are sleeping in
their car like not in the street like in
sleeping bikes but in their cars
directly in front of this office and
that one one lady and multiple people
actually told me that they were had been
staying there for three days polowsky
says the ukrainian woman he helped left
the office empty-handed that day only
able to get an appointment online a
month later in paris ina baranov's
mother was finally able to get her visa
after a lawyer became involved alexandra
aslanova's daughters eventually received
their visas too after several weeks of
unexplained delays
finally allowing these families to begin
new chapters now that their limbo is
over at last heather urex west global
news